[Musique]
bonsoir effectivement de bombes ma
position is it un peu particulière parce
que je ne parle pas je vais pas parler
de mes racines
mais je vais parler en fait de des
racines de populations auxquelles je me
suis consacré effectivement depuis en
fait j'ai recalculé c'est pas 40 ans a
fait 36 ans en fait ça fait quand même
déjà un bon moment
alors j'en parle en anthropologue gens
parlent pas en originaire de cette
société c'est effectivement une société
je veux pas je vais pas vous faire
l'ethnographie de cette société n'est
pas question ici de de faire une grande
conférence
c'est une petite société donc les huit
nier comme on l'a rappelé qui est en
fait sont bien mieux connu sous le nom
de co2 l'émotion générale les appels
déco c'est pas le nom qu'il se donne
winje en fait c'est un l'étymologie
juillet c'est simplement comme bourdon
beaucoup de populations ou onyema donc
les hommes les blés legault c'est dieu
il n'y est même assez les gens les gens
de dieu ce qui est une dénomination
assez classique
alors je me suis intéressé alors
l'anthropologie c1 c'est un domaine très
vaste
on peut faire pas mal de choses
anthropologie après il ya à boire et à
manger dans ce domaine là on peut
finalement faire des études sur ces
sociétés qui sont des études dans lequel
on se reconnaît
parce que partout si vous voulez on
trouve dans dans dans le monde on trouve
des gens qui ont des intérêts qui qui
sont les rapports de force qui sont dans
des rapports de pouvoir
elle lui nier n'échappe pas évidemment
pas ce genre de à ce genre de pratiques
donc on peut quand on fait de
l'anthropologie se contenter de
travailler sur les rapports de force sur
les stratégies sur les pouvoirs
politiques sur l'histoire etc
et on peut se reconnaître puisque
finalement on est on est nous aussi des
gens pleins d'intérêt plein de rapports
de pouvoir plein de stratégie on peut
aussi étudier et faire d'anthropologie
j'irai dans un père ses percées
perspective de de ce que roger bastide
un anthropologue français appelés
l'éclairage en retour c'est à dire cette
idée que étudié c'était africaine pardon
à part dans ce riche et très bon je me
laisse emporter étudier les sociétés
africaines qui sont évidemment
différentes qu'un rapport différentes
par exemple domaines social économique
peut être intéressant et conflits pour
questionner les sociétés modernes
européenne et donc il ya eu su aussi
toutes sortes de travaux qui se sont
engagés sur cette piste là en disant ces
cités africaines sont sont intéressantes
on soit parce qu'elles ont développé
d'autres modèles sociaux d'autres
manières de finalement tout combiné
l'économique et le social qui est
intéressante à étudier qui
éventuellement veut être une considérée
comme une base critique par rapport à
susciter moderne cette société
capitaliste et c'est dans ce type de da
proches
on reconnaît ces sociétés se dire que
celles ci ne sont pas exotique elles
sont pas différentes
on reconnaît les rapports de force on
reconnaît les rapports entre économie
sociale et c'est ce que sur quoi je
m'attache depuis des années j'ai fait
beaucoup de choses dans ma carrière j'ai
pas travailler qu'un subventions et sur
le sujet chez dans cette population là
je me suis intéressé aux questions aux
univers donc grandes funérailles aux
rites funéraires notamment rites
animistes funéraire
et aux théories du rapport entre le
corps et l'âme que qui sont impliqués en
fait dans ces rites funéraires et c'est
là au fond où on se dit que
l'anthropologie permet de refléter de
donner une image de ces sociétés dans
lequel on ne se reconnaît pas et
finalement c'est pour ça qu'on passe 36
ans comme je lé fais à travailler sur ce
genre de terrain c'est parce que en font
ce type de société lorsqu'elle met en
scène ce type de pratique fait rituels
sont tellement étrange tellement
exotique tellement difficile à
comprendre qu'il faut et extraits ex
beaucoup de temps en fait pour se mettre
au service de ceux ci était d'essayer ou
fondant dégager le sens au fond pour moi
l'anthropologie c'est d'abord l'humidité
de devoir se mettre au niveau de ce que
les gens ont à nous dire
les paysans de base les devins les gens
avec qui je travaille les aînés les
chefs de terre mettre de l'eau etc sont
des gens qui parlent facilement
simplement on finit assez vite par les
lacets sur leur pose des questions assez
inintéressante donc il faut constamment
se mettre nu au niveau intellectuel de
ce qu'ils on nous a à nous dire d'accord
et c'est ça qui prend du temps c'est
pour ça que finalement vain depuis des
années je travaille effectivement à
faire la place en moi de ce ces
informations qui doivent venir qui
doivent être transmises et que je dois
analyser au meilleur de ce que les gens
nous disent c'est pour moi finalement le
seul intérêt c'est d'être au niveau et
de la seule responsabilité morale qu'on
a par rapport à ces populations c'est
finalement
et bien de de restituer le plus
fidèlement possible ce qui ne faisons ce
qui nous ont à ce qu'ils ont à nous dire
ne pas ne pas faire des interprétations
erronées ou des interprétations rapide
et c'est de dire deuxième thème sur
lequel on dirait que les cela a sur la
réflexion sur les racines sur la
question des racines
si je reprends quelques instants le cas
de ma société d'études fait c'est des
gens je réussir à construire un petit
peu l'histoire c'est une société ce
qu'on appelle en anthropologie me
société de la frontière c'est en fait
c'est des gens qui sont arrivés c'est en
fait boromo seul e on dirait la capitale
du pays minier donc boromo ce n'est pas
une ville spécialement oncle avait un
c'est pas c'est une ville ce con qu'on
visite
lorsqu'on passe entre ouaga et bobo il
ya rien de très compliqué là dedans et
ce sont des gens des populations qui se
sont installés installé donc au long du
moun sur la rive droite du rhône à
partir j'irai du la fin 17e essai des
populations extrêmement mélanger en fait
les huits nié en tant qu'ethnie sont
constitués de petits groupes qui sauf
qu'ils ont fuies souvent lors ce ces
sociétés d'origine et vous trouvez dans
ces groupes dans ce groupe
par exemple des peuls dennoun à des
mossi della guerra
bref des bois bat toute une série
d'ethnies qui sont venus en fait composé
finalement s'est étirée tenues
originales à partir du xviie siècle
ce qui veut dire aussi que les racines
de ces populations là sont très
mélangées et si vous étudiez très très
précisément les différents aspects de
leur vie sociale rituel symbolique et
c'est vous auront voix de ray compte par
exemple que maintien par certains
aspects du pouvoir politique
il ressent beaucoup au moci par par
exemple la manière d'anti
considère que le néré est une culture
des hommes
il ressemble effectivement phone une
production qui réservé aux hommes
il ressemble beaucoup au moci par
d'autres aspects par exemple et les
aspects rites liés à la première
grossesse
eh bien ils ont un peu les mêmes rites
que les dagara et les lobbys si vous
prenez les masques je sais pas si on a
il ya eu une série de deux de photos qui
ont été pris sur le terrain et qui
datent de 85 en fait c'est un de mes
premiers premier nommé premier terrain
vous allez voir qu'il ya quelques photos
de masques si vous prenez par exemple le
système des masques voilà on voit l'un
c'est typique de la société de nouna se
tiennnent à vous retrouver exactement
les mêmes eaux pratiquement les mêmes
types de masques donc en fait c'est une
société on pourrait dire que fait de
pièces et de morceaux 1
l'intérêt c'est effectivement de montrer
que à partir de ces pièces est ses
morceaux différents frais de serre à
partir de ces éléments composites
finalement est née une société original
avec sa langue originale
bon ça c'est le premier aspect sur
lequel je voulais insister
alors l'autre aspect c'est la question
du changement dans ces contextes là
alors d'une part
on pourrait dire que les huiliers comme
beaucoup de sociétés finalement des
dispositifs faut faire face aux
changements dans la mesure où dans ces
sociétés
ce qui est important c'est pas les
baptêmes ou les mariages mairie
funérailles en fait c'est dans le
domaine funéraire dans le domaine des
rites funéraires en fête se passe les
plus grandes pressions la fois
économique sociale mais aussi les plus
grands changements et en fait signé avec
un mécanisme de règle régulation pour
élire les changements tiers qui savent
très bien que la vie actuelle ce
difficile c'est compliqué on n'a pas
d'argent on arrive difficilement à
réunir les gens et puis de toute façon
ça coûte cher et surtout les reds à vide
funéraire en milieu animistes et donc il
avait une institution qui était le
l'institution du chef de terre le chef
de terre quand il est intronisé tous les
chefs de terre sont intronisés
mais s'ils subissent une intronisation
en fait ils peuvent réguler changer les
règles en matière de rites funéraires
par exemple ils peuvent décider que au
lieu d'avoir un mois de funérailles
on doit recevoir les filles des oncles
maternels et fil des ans en maternelle
du père et figuiers fil des ans le
matériel de la mer les lbo etc
eh bien on va réduire sa une semaine
tout ça simplement porte pour que les
coûts économiques pour la famille du
d'ailleurs soit moins important donc on
a si vous voulez en interne des
dispositifs qui permettait effectivement
finalement de faire face aux pressions
des changements liés à la modernité
maintenant ce qui se passe et qui est
beaucoup plus compliqué c'est que
évidemment les changements ne porte pas
seulement sur les funérailles
il ya par exemple un domaine enfin je
dirais la définition même du jeu serré 2
du bon vignes et de l'homme minier c'est
ce qu'ils disent eux mêmes c'est l'homme
qui charge le monde
l'homme qui charge le monde sur sa tête
et au fond c'est pas très différent je
dirais de la conception de son cas
l'idée de l'esclave du peuple pour moi
c'est un peu la même chose simplement
que ces questions de responsabilité
cette cette manière de cette volonté
d'assumer d'assumer la responsabilité
est de plus en plus rares en fait
l'homme chat qui chargeaient le monde
c'était quelqu'un qui souvent faisait
appel à ses aînés ou à ses chefs qui
eux-mêmes faisait appel gérait la
religion aux esprits au génie aux
fétiches etc
et c'est dans ce contexte là que se
faisait finalement la charge du monde
charge du monde
on avait à charge le monde et on avait à
charge le monde à travers effectivement
une série de relations entre les hommes
entre les jeunes et les vieux
et entre les vieux et les esprits les
fétichistes
évidemment le monde moderne c'est un
monde qui ne se quittent pas très
compatible avec ce type de philosophie
je dirais et on a de plus en plus de
gens qui se défile qui veulent plus
charger du monde qui veulent simplement
pensé à eux faire ce qu'ils ont envie de
faire et pas grand chose d'autre et
effectivement je tirais une de grande
partie de ce qui se passe actuellement
en fin de ce qu'on voudra se dérouler
tir est journellement devant ses yeux
quand on connaît assez observateurs
c'est notamment la fin des rites
funéraires traditionnelle et puis je
tirais dépression alors on pourrait
appeler ça j'ai appelé ça on est on est
dans une situation dans lesquels on
entendait des phénomènes de crise de
d'engendrement c'est au fond la société
n'est plus en état
finalement de générer des règles pour
faire face aux changements parce que le
changement
il est trop rapide il concerne trop de
secteurs à la fois pas seulement les
funérailles d'autres secteurs et puis
qu'il est multiforme d'accord et j'ai
observe de plus en plus de situations
dans lesquelles par exemple je vois un
jeune qui veut voir c'est vieux c'est
pour ça que je dis qu'on est dans des
crises d'engendrement les crises
d'engendrement cd crise dans lequel
finalement les enfants deviennent les
parents de leurs parents et scènes
typiques de ce genre de situation dans
lequel les enfants deviennent
parents de leurs parents c'est des
enfants qui viennent dire à leurs yeux à
leur père et leur mère
dépêche toi te convertir à l'islam au
christianisme parce que moi j'ai pas les
moyens de te payer des tenues de
cérémonies coutumières et donc tu
n'auras rien du tout si tu ne le fais
pas d'accord et on est de plus en plus
de ce genre de de situation actuellement
donc on est véritablement dans des
crises d'engendrement qui sont
extrêmement douloureuses fin difficile
difficile à gérer
dernier point sur lequel je voudrais
parler ce soir c'est en tant que
anthropologue j'ai cherché tout le temps
finalement à bon à être en relation avec
les gens et ville bien évidemment mais
surtout finalement à l'étroit dans une
relation de don contre don serge géant
bt tous ces gens là depuis des années
des années leur poser des questions
innombrables sur l'état ce sujet et
c'est observer leurs rituels tout ça et
finalement qu'est-ce que je pouvais leur
donner en retour
et comme c'est une société à masquer je
me suis dit à un moment donné ça
pourrait peut-être pas être pas si mal
de faire un festival de masques et bon
j'ai réussi à trouver un peu de sou du
côté de la suisse qui en faisant
accepter effectivement de financer un
festival de masquer ce qui s'est passé
sur une dizaine d'années donc avec une
conception un peu original il s'agissait
pas de réunir tous les masques à bord au
moment d'essayer d'avoir un espèce de
festival itinérant dans quatre villages
différents qui permettait chaque village
chaque village permettant de regrouper
différents villages entre eux et
finalement on avait un festival qui est
en sur quatre jours alors pour moi au
départ c'est une opération demande
contre-don ce j'avais trouvé ça comme
manière finalement de remercier ces gens
avec qui je travaille et que souvent
comme je disais jambette avec mes
questions innombrables inapproprié
bizarre etc mais je me suis rendu compte
et c'est là où la question des racines
est intéressante parce que les racines
bien évidemment ces des racines interne
mais quelque part le regard externe est
depuis ce gérer de plus en plus
d'ailleurs le regard externe sur ses
racines compte énormément dans la
reproduction dans la consolidation de
ses racines interne au fond ce que les
gens m'ont dit au bout de quelques temps
qu'on avait commencé à faire c'est ces
différentes journées de festival c'est
enfin on a notre projet les musulmans
leur projet et chrétiens dans leur
projet et nous les animistes on à leurs
proches dans un autre projet d'accord et
c'était ça pour le langage là était
vraiment dans ce langage là qu'ils en
parlaient 1
ça veut dire qu'effectivement les luttes
son fortin sur les guides je dirais
lakers les guerres de religion sur le
terrain sont fortes et effectivement ce
festival moi je n'avais pas perçu comme
ça je n'avais pas fait ça du tout dans
une perspective de consolider quoi que
ce soit aux deux ou d'affaiblir quoi que
ce soit d'autre
mais je me suis rendu compte que c'était
effectivement comme ça que c'était bien
interprété alors faut pas trop non plus
être enfin il faut rester assez assez
mesuré dans ce genre du succès parce
qu'au fond la culture par définition ça
ça ne s'est pas des activités
génératrices de revenus c'est pas c'est
avec la culture que vous pouvez financer
autofinancé des événements comme ceux-là
donc quelque part quand vous commencez
un festival de vasques
l'idéal ce serait de ne jamais s'arrêter
vous savez que les bailleurs il
fonctionne pas comme ça et d'ailleurs
ils financent pendant quatre ans ou cinq
ans je finisse pas c'est difficile
finance pas sur 50 ans d'accord et donc
effectivement en même temps qu'eux on
voit bien jeu
je suis très très content de cette
opération parce qu'effectivement j'ai eu
l'impression de pouvoir articuler une
demande interne avec mon besoin externe
de rendre quelque chose en même temps
les gens me disent sur le terrain tu a
enterré un cadavre mais les pieds
continue de se re sortir et donc il faut
enterrer le cadavre réussir enterrer
aussi ses pieds c'est pas évident
heureusement la mairie de boromo a
décidé de reprendre en charge
effectivement cette opération donc
quelque part on peut imaginer pouvoir
continue effectivement dans la durée à
avoir ce type de digérer dans deux
forces externes qui vient pour certains
aspects j'irai retarder un petit peu le
délitement complète sa société sur le
plan culturel
merci
[Applaudissements]